our body is bombarded by several
pathogens
every day and these pathogens include
viruses
bacteria fungi and even helminth
let's look at how our immune system
responds
against these helminth infection now let
me tell you that
parasitic worms or hell means which
frequently affect humans
can be broadly classified into three
groups
first the stones which are the tapeworms
second the nematodes which are the round
worms and then
tremators which are the flukes generally
they
enter our body via intestinal tract and
they can contaminate
food or water and they can come from the
fecal matter of
infected person now let me tell you
these
helminths are exclusively extracellular
and therefore they are more accessible
towards the immune system to mount an
immune response
though they are accessible but they
cannot divide inside our body
to that extent but they can mature
inside our body so the immune system is
rather
mild compared to let's say a virus or a
bacteria so let us look at how this
immune system
works against these kind of helmets
so let me tell you that more than 300
million people
are infected with cytostoma infection
every year which can cause severe
symptoms
so let us look at how our body reacts to
these helminth infection infection
cysostoma has an interesting life cycle
they spend some amount of time
in our body and sometimes they also
spend in snails tissue
and their eggs or mature forms could be
also found in
fresh water so let's say you went for a
swimming
and you suddenly get exposed to the
infectious life phase of these cyso
stomach which is known as
circularia so circularia can drill hole
in your skin and can get into your
system
and from there it can get into your
bloodstream
now when securia is inside the blood it
would be detected by your complement
proteins which are abundant in your
bloodstream
then there are many cell types which can
recognize these complement proteins and
have
complement receptors on their surface
such as dendritic cells
and macrophages so they would mount the
first level of immune response
other than that there would be
antibodies
which are against to these sickaria this
antibody would code the surface of this
cardia and make it weaker making it
difficult for them to survive
then other cell types such as eosinophil
neutrophil and nk cells can
mount an immune response so let us look
at this process in
bit more details and in step by step
fashion
so here is our saquaria which is coated
by the complement proteins
so obviously there would be some plasma
cells which would be generated which are
specific against these
zikaria and they would secrete
ige antibody so it's important to know
that ige antibodies
are key player in this process now ige
antibody would bind to specific antigens
present on this
area then mast cell
which is capable of binding to ige via
fc receptor would
degranulate muscle would
eventually recruit eosinophil
neutrophils etc onto these
circular larvae because eosinophil
neutrophil both have
fc receptors and all of these can
take part in antibody dependent cellular
cytotoxicity responses
now another important cell population
that takes a
major role immunity in the immunity
against cysostoma
is the th1 cell th one cell can secrete
interferon gamma which indeed can
activate macrophages so it would
increase the activity of macrophages and
enhance petrocytosis now
other than that eosinophil muscle
neutrophil
all of them can secrete certain amount
of chemokines
which would ultimately attract other
blood cell
by the way while fixing complement there
are
c3a and c5a which are potent enough
latoxin
so obviously they can also attract other
blood cells and create
inflammation in the system so due to
inflammation in the system
cell types such as neutrophil and
monocytes would get out of the blood
vessels
and they would reach the tissue space
where the infection happened
so obviously what would happen is they
create
a strong immune response against these
tricharia larva
now let's look at how complement system
can
eliminate the pathogens so obviously
come complement systems
decorate these pathogen kind of
optionalizing it making it
more difficult for the pathogen to
survive but obviously these ige
antibodies can bind on the surface
and ultimately lead to formation of the
membrane attack complex
which leads to fluid um disbalance
and due to this osmolarity disbalance
there would be lysis of the pathogen
so overall we looked at how our body
reacts to
cysostomy infection how our complement
systems and innate immune components
in fact can mount an immune response
against them
obviously we also looked at adaptive
immune components such as
ige producing mast cells and th1 cells
can also mount an immune response
against them
so i hope you enjoyed this video if you
like this short video give it a quick
thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and do let me know in the comment how
you like my videos thank you guys